foreign
tool Google ads
what is Google ads
Google ads is a online platform or an
interface or a tool we can share a
software which is developed by Google
to help the advertisers to run different
kind of ads on different publishing
sites or publishing platforms if I make
it more simple for you suppose you are
an Advertiser and you sell a digital
marketing course
so you know that the bulk of the traffic
would come from Google because this is
the most used search engine in the world
so when we type this we see a lot of
results here
and when we start a website it is very
difficult to rank organically or free or
through the SEO on the very first few
pages
with the help of Google ads in a very
starting days we can rank on the top
like
this this this
[Music]
or this Advertiser so these are the four
top positions which right now has been
given to the advertisers who are playing
or who are running their ad using Google
ads
on a first page we see seven of such ads
four on the top I've shown you and three
on the bottom
so these are the maximum placements
which we see on a Google search page
this is the first kind of AD which can
be created under the Google ads tool
which we would definitely going to learn
today how to create such beautiful ad
copy second ad which generally we see on
different
sides like if I'll open any new site if
I'll open any block site if I open a
site like a speed test.net then you
would see a beautiful banner or a
responsive ad like these these and these
okay how come I am able to say that
these are ads so if you'll just hover on
this this would say ads by Google
ads by Google so a different Advertiser
this is a Paramount this is from GoDaddy
and the publishing site which has been
selected by these advertisers is
speedtest.net
the Third Kind of AD which we generally
see on Google itself but in a different
colors and shape is called shopping ad
so if I just search suppose I want black
formal
shoes
then
the add copy is changed it is not
like a text at which we have seen
earlier
though there is no text ad in this
search but we have just seen in the case
of digital marketing course
but it is an ad we can see from here
okay so this is called a shopping ad
then if I go and if I'll open
YouTube
and if I'll search a term maybe I am in
a search of email
for beginners course
and if I just play any of the videos a
random one
and before the video plays
certainly we can skip after
five to six seconds and sometimes we see
a ad which streams but cannot be skipped
so these are video ads which again
created by this beautiful tool Google
ads one more ad Mobile Installation but
I cannot show you as I am from the
desktop though I would able to show you
the
screenshot of the same
now coming to the part why Google ad is
so important okay so I'll be just quick
now because we have to be making the
account today and also the campaign
Google ad is important in many ways
because Google ad helps us to increase
the visibility of our products increase
the visibility of our brand because you
can just imagine you were there
on Google but you were somewhere on
Sixth page or probably you know in the
next pagination if I'll just go and not
beyond that there are the results but
suppose you are you are on the sixth
page so we can just assume that nobody
goes beyond first or second I don't know
if you or not but I don't go okay and
that's how the service is 97 of people
doesn't go beyond first to second page
so that means we have to be on a first
page if we really want to sell our
products so increasing that visibility
of our brand
would take time if we just keep waiting
for SEO results to come or to give us
the first page or a second page ranking
so for that reason for our quick results
by making a relevant ad copy and by
targeting the right keywords we can
increase availability we can increase
the brand awareness we can increase the
traffic
okay we can also use a beautiful way of
retargeting or a remarketing where
people are able to recall our brand or
able to make the decisions if at a first
time they were not actually taken
suppose I say they went to my site
or any of the sides but in a very first
time they have not given me a result so
for me as this website the result is
getting the lead form field this is a
lead form and this is the page where we
have reached and where wherever you know
you would see a relevant page connected
to the particular ad that page is called
a landing page okay so this landing page
has a Content this landing page has an
objective to get the form field and this
landing page has a CTA which is called a
call to action okay so for me as an
Advertiser or as a digital marketer or
as a campaign manager of this brand did
you perform it's very important to get
as many as people to this page plus it
is the most important part that I get a
lot of form field and lot of CTA clicks
or this call to action clicks but every
time I cannot assume I have to be
realistic as well if even hundred or
thousand users have landed to my website
from the ad I cannot expect more than
three to five percent conversions okay
so if I say suppose 100 users have
reached my page today since morning so I
can only expect three to five percent of
leads or three to five users would have
filled the data but when we talk about a
remarketing then it is about retargeting
those guys who have reached here but did
not
filled up the data or did not convert it
or in the same case if I have taken them
to the black formal shoes site they
reached to the landing page or a product
page but did not bought the product so
for that reason we can always retarget
them using the website data so all these
things are very important once we start
learning Google ads deeply then you
would know how these works like you know
how the functionality of of these works
like okay so they are talking about the
same thing rlsa is retargeting list of
search ads we are able to Target people
who have not converted okay who have not
converted okay
then it is also used for
um I think I've talked about branding
now they're talking about how these
strategies work like so we generally
work on the different bid uh strategies
like how you pay to Google so the most
important one when it comes to Google
search ad this is called search art or
techstart is CPC so CPC is cost per
click okay now I'm talking about a very
important technical term the very first
technical term probably we have just
talked uh about the broadness off of the
Google ads how that is you know
important to increase The Branding
visibility and traffic we did talked
about the remarketing a bit but now I am
getting into the campaign terms which is
going to be very important if you want
to learn today how to create a search
camp in a search art so the very first
thing is bidding strategy so we pay CPC
or it is also called PPC when we are
doing this sort of an ad which is called
text ad this means cost per click or pay
per click so when somebody clicks on
this clicks on this clicks on this as a
user as a Searcher as a viewer then only
a Advertiser would pay to Google
this is what PPC means pay per click
marketing so Advertiser is getting
advantage that till the time the ad has
only been shown
he is not paying any Penny to Google but
the moment our very first user comes and
clicks on it then the amount of certain
bid value starts deducting from the
advertisers Google ads account which we
certainly going to be creating for you
guys as well in a while okay so you
create a Google ads account you put some
money into it you start running the ad
of different sort text ad Banner ad
video ad shopping ad and the movement
somebody clicks or somebody watches a
video or somebody takes any action on
your ads then only you pay most of the
times okay that is what the CPC strategy
works like
then also it is a very important part
that we should know how we are measuring
the results so in anywhere in the
digital marketing if you talk from my
experience I know we are only able to
get better results or we are only able
to get more conversions if we are just
not running the ad we have to be first
researching how the ads should be
created we have to be working on the
areas which should not be filled uh we
should not be left unfilled and it
should be focused on the audience it
should be focused on certain
parameters and after running the ad also
it is very important to keep measuring
the performance and optimizing
optimizing and optimizing further or
otherwise taking care in the next
campaign okay so I think superficially
we have talked about lot of things on a
go why not just to get into the Google
ads now see how the account is created
for free and then let's make a campaign
first and we'll come back and we
understand we'll try to understand some
of the important things like you know
there are metrics which we have to be
seeing there are formats okay so formats
I've already talked about okay so this
is the text that I've already shown then
there is a a banner ad which I've shown
you on the you know speedtest.net there
is another kind of an ad image that
again you know you see on a different
platforms like websites and apps then
there is a app ad which I could not show
you practically because I am logged in
from my desktop so this was the fifth
kind of an ad which I was talking about
a Mobile Installation ad so this
probably you see only on most of the
time on a mobile because as an
Advertiser he would want that
installation Button as a CTA should be
directly placed under the ad so that if
person searches for something on a
mobile then the ad is directly showing
them the installation button and the app
can be downloaded into their mobile
gadgets okay so now then there is a
video ad which we already seen in the
shopping ad I've already shown you okay
then there's a another ad which is just
a call only though it is again you know
created by the Google ads only we will
see
now coming to create the Google ads okay
so first of all
creating the campaign we need to be
having a Google ads account that's a
very first requirement so I'll just help
you now how you create a Google ads
account for free by using your Gmail ID
okay so we go to Google
let me just search probably here itself
and we type Google ads just ensure that
you are logged in with any of your Gmail
ID
and then we see Google ads
on a top
then we just need to click this
and
once you reach to this page you have to
click get started
after get started probably in my case
you would see a different screen because
I have lot of accounts created a lot of
clients accounts are there but in your
case it will show new Google Earth
account
like this
so I will repeat my steps so that you're
not confused
so you go on Google
you type Google ads
you click Google ads the very first
result
or either if it is not showing in your
country in your location then you have
to just find ads.google.com
and you click get started
okay the moment you click get started
you would directly reach to this page
okay that's why I just repeated my steps
because I have been taken to some other
page where my already created accounts
were showing but in your case after just
clicking get started it will directly
going to take you to this page now here
you have to ensure that you are not
clicking anything why because this has
brought us to the express mode Express
mode is more of the kind like automated
or a smart mode which is created by
Google for uh making the quick ads you
know it is not going to be showing you
all the exhaustive settings or you know
advanced settings inside so for that
reason what we do we go down we just you
know I've just I've just scroll down
okay and then switch to expert mode
okay I'll again repeat when we click
this get started we reach to this page
where it takes us to the smart or
Express mode where we don't have to be
doing anything we scroll down and we
click on a switch to export mode
once we click that
then you would see few things which you
have just seen in the PPT probably that
what is your objective why you have come
here we have come here to increase your
sales leads website traffic and XYZ
things but because right now I'm just
teaching you or just letting you know
how the account is created then we can
ignore these tabs for a moment of course
in a while we'll talk about these as
well so we'll just scroll down and we'll
create a account without a campaign as I
said we are going in a sequence so we
are not creating the campaign first I am
considering most of the users would not
have the Google ad account as of now so
I am going that way so you create the
account first without a campaign so when
you click this
then you see
there are a few basic questions been
asked like from which country you are
billing would be which time zone you
want to follow or which currency you
would be paying in okay once this is
done just click submit
okay just click submit
once this is done congrats you're all
done okay then you just need to click on
explore your account
and this takes you to the
dashboard of this beautiful tool Google
ads from where we can start our journey
of making the very first
yeah okay so now let's again come back
to the PPD because our account is
created now before making the campaign
what all things should be cleared let's
discuss
okay so you can create all these kind of
campaigns or with all these goals inside
the Google ads which we have just
learned how to be uh creating the
account okay how the account is created
we can create the campaign to increase
the sales we can in we can increase the
leads by running the ads you can
increase our website traffic we can work
for the product branding or a
consideration we can also work for brand
awareness and app promotion okay these
are the subdefined goals or predefined
goals before we jump into the campaign
making of a search or a display or a
video okay I I hope these are these all
are very much defined or self-defined
one so I don't have to be you know
telling you what is sales and what is
branding and what is awareness but still
if you feel so in a while I will just
going to throw some light on it okay
then
setting up the ad group so I will be
just making all this practically with
you so we don't again you don't have to
be understanding all this now coming to
some of the metrics which you would see
inside
the campaign once that is created so
let's just go back and
see one of the
ads from any of my clients so that we
can learn better
only I'll just open in a different tab
okay
so if I just have to show you
probably I can just use right now the
demo account of assembly line where
important metrics
we can discuss which which has already
been given in the PPT but of course I
would just show you how they look like
inside the campaigns or inside the
Google ads account so if we move to the
dashboard when we have created and if we
have already been running any campaigns
and we want to see results or any of the
metrics then what we do we go into all
campaigns
and from here we can see all sort of
campaigns created in the past okay
because I wanna see only the results
from the search campaigns because there
are all kind of campaigns been created
here like video campaigns and display
and all so what I can do I can click
this
this law of uh navigation menu on the
top left
and then I can just select the search
campaigns
when this is selected
only these search campaigns would be
visible
now if I just go on any of the campaign
suppose inside
then this breadcrumbs changes earlier I
was only in the all campaigns then I
just selected search campaigns and now
inside the search campaigns I have
selected a specific campaign okay so
considering suppose this was the
campaign I have run in the January for
any of my digital marketing sales okay
or any of my product sales or any of my
services lead generation XYZ objectives
could have been okay now coming to the
main part
from The Matrix point of view so we see
here
that there are
results been shown of course because
this is a demo account so you don't see
numbers we can always change the dates
like suppose I want to see the uh result
of last 30 days so I would just go here
and this would show these many
Impressions have come Impressions like
how many times the ad is just been seen
okay impression means just how many
times the ad been seen okay then it
would show how many times the ad
actually been clicked okay how many
times had been clicked assuming 100
times The Impressions have come and two
clicks have come so the percentage which
is basically a ratio of a clicks to
impression is called CTR
the click-through rate which is the next
one
clicks impression and CTR okay so
click-through rate is the ratio of
impression to clicks your ad been shown
hundred of times or 100 times probably
but only click today for three times so
your CTR is three percent your ad been
shown
100 times but been clicked seven times
so your CTR is seven percent which is a
very good number okay anything around
five to ten is good okay we don't get to
see lot of Clicks in our initial days
because people do trust the brands which
are already established but slowly
gradually with the right branding with
the right awareness our click rate
increases our CTR increases okay then
comes your average CPC which certainly
you would see here as well so average
CPC is a price which you actually end up
in paying for every click
okay so there is a bid value bid value
means when you started to create your
account or with a campaign of a search
then you decide for certain keywords
that how much money you would pay for
every click okay that is called a bid
price which we certainly see here okay
and once you start getting the clicks
after running your campaign then the
exact pricing been shown as a average
CPC price okay then comes the cost cost
is basically going to be your
multiplication of number of clicks
you've got with the average CPC you have
paid suppose you have got 100 clicks
today and for every click you paid five
rupees
so 100 into 5 going to be 500 or if you
uh understand by the dollars so suppose
for every click you have paid one USD so
for 100 clicks you pay 100 USD by the
end of a day okay that is going to be
your day cost or average cost you have
paid for
particular ad on a particular day that
is also understood by saying daily
budget you have spent okay so if I have
allotted that I would pay 900 rupees a
day and 9 900 rupees a day in the
average of the CPC if I would have
probably 10 Rupees so I will get 90
clicks okay because nine tick ticks into
10 Rupees for a click I'm going to
exhaust my 900 per day budget if this
would have been 100 dollars
and then 100 clicks multiplied by one
dollar will going to exhaust my hundred
dollars per day okay this is how Google
calculates like for how much uh budget
you want to run the ad for and on
various factors your average cost per
click is decided okay this is the uh
understanding of all these terms cost
per conversion and conversion depends
that how your next step actually been
designed so by Next Step I mean suppose
if I talk about this particular ad only
a person clicks and person reaches here
okay so we can Define the conversions
like suppose 100 people have reached
here on the landing page this means 100
clicks would have happened okay so the
dashboard would say
thousand Impressions 100 clicks one
rupee 100 rupee okay one rupee being the
average CPC 100 clicks we have received
and we have spent 100 rupees but it
doesn't mean that all those 100 clicks
which actually
took the users to the landing page would
have been converted okay so when the
conversion code has been placed on the
confirmation page which opens after the
conversion happens or after the goal
completes so that actually tells us how
many people got converted or how many
people actually uh fulfilled or
completed our objective of goal whatever
it was lead generation sales download
brochure any of the subscriptions any of
the ctOS we talk about okay
so uh talking about the numbers suppose
only three people or two people or two
users have filled this data okay so the
numbers in my dashboard would be like
1000 Impressions have been shown 100
clicks have come means 100 people have
reached to the landing page but only two
conversions have happened okay and the
cost for all the clicks would be like
100 rupees because average CPC was one
rupee okay so when the conversion is 2
then we can say that our conversion rate
was two percent why because out of 100
Lakes I was only able to get two people
across the confirmation page or across
that CTA which was a call to action of
buy now shop now or sign up or download
whatever it was that is called a
convergence and conversion rate two
percent cost per conversion can only
also be divided like two conversions
I've got in 100 rupees so my cost per
conversion would be 50 rupees okay my
average CPC is one my click's been
hundred my Impressions been thousand my
CTA been ten percent how 100 divided by
1000 CTR 10 percent I have a cpc1 cost
becomes 100 rupees my conversion has
been two that's why my conversion rate
is two percent and my cost per
conversion comes like 50 why because
I've got two conversions on the spent of
100 that brings 50 rupees here
I hope this is clear if I have to just
demonstrate
just wait
so that this is basically you know
uh been captured in your heads with more
clarity so I'm just going to
use a normal example
impressions
the same numbers which I just explained
so that you know
okay so this is cost per conversion
suppose your ad received thousand
impressions today 100 clicks have come
so your CTR becomes ten percent because
that is how this is calculated clicks by
Impressions where our CPC was one rupee
or it has
a billion dollars so your cost would be
100 rupees
or hundred dollars
you've got two conversions means two
people or two users have uh bought
anything or have subscribed or have just
you know completed that call to action
and the conversion rate for that reason
would be 2 divided by hundred so two
percent
and cost per conversion in this case
would be 50 rupees because you have paid
100 rupees for two conversions and in
this case it would be fifty dollars just
a hypothetical number did not be very
much worried about the numbers okay with
the high priest okay this would change
certainly when we do the research of our
keywords
okay
now coming
to the part how now these ads been
created that's the most important part
how we create a beautiful ad copies and
all that okay so we go
into the campaign making by all campaign
and then we click on a campaign
we click on a new campaign
Google ads most of the time works low
nowadays so you have to be a bit patient
with this and then we click on a create
campaign without a goal guidance or we
can always click website traffic lead
sales okay these all four can be created
uh for the Google ad search campaign you
know we can only use these four for the
search app because if I'll just click
this this will not allow me to create
search and this only allows video ad if
I'll click this this only allows display
and video ad this only allows mobile ad
and this is for the local so if I have
to create a search ad like this or a
text ad like this so I have to be either
creating through sales leads or website
or either without a guidance so I'll
just going to be teaching you all the
settings inside so that you know the
Google ads uh you know search ad
settings in advanced level so I'm just
taking without a rule
then you click search ads
our focus is just to create search ad
you can leave this part right now
because your conversions are not being
created we'll do in maybe in the next
session when we'll talk about the
advanced settings and website visit is
my Premiere goal and suppose I am
running we add for any of these sites
probably I'm running the ad for
just see if I can get the simple
learning page so this remarkable search
marketing
just a minute guys
yeah digital marketing
course
click on continue
and then the very first thing you see
bidding which we have just learned that
we pay on the cost per click basis so
clicks
and you can always set up your
bid limit that I do not want to pay more
than suppose one rupee a click or two
rupiah click or five rupee attack
okay and there is another
thing which we have to be discussing
before we talk about the bid limit so
let me just take you to the
Keyword Planner so this comes from here
tool settings
Keyword Planner
so that we get an overview that how much
actually we should be paying for every
keyword we are running the ad for
suppose my keyword for which I want to
run the ad is digital marketing code
that is the premiere keyword or the most
searched keyword by which
the ads of a competitors also are
showing and also I want to show my ad
for okay so what I would do I would just
go into this beautiful tool I again
repeat my steps I can just go tool in
settings
Keyword Planner open in a right tab why
so that your existing campaign settings
are not Disturbed okay you come here you
click this and you click discover new
keywords and you search your term like
digital marketing course
click get results
and then you are able to see
digital marketing course in the period
of last one year in India of course you
can change the country to U.S Canada
Australia anywhere and you would see in
the last one year how many search
queries on a monthly basis have come for
this particular keyword in addition you
see lot of suggestions as well suppose
we're just sticking around one keyword
right now to understand the bid part and
all so we see that we got around 1
million searches in India for this
particular keyword with the competition
of medium competition medium means that
most of the advertisers who are selling
this digital marketing course been
running the ad for the This this term or
not if this competition would have been
high then I should have ignored this or
would have changed the keyword but this
is medium so I would take this and this
you know talks about the bid value this
is the low term and this is the high
term like low price means this is the
lowest price any of the advertisers
would have paid this year for this
particular term to show the ad and this
is the highest bid price which any of
the advertisers would have paid in this
year for this term so they doesn't tell
which part of year it was which
Advertiser it was but at least we get a
fair idea that our bid value would be
around 46 to 195. so we go bit smart
we go on the average price suppose a bit
46 so I'll just go 30 40 percent over
this price so suppose I take 30 percent
around 12 rupees or 13 rupees so that
makes it 15 and around 60 rupees so this
is the bid value I am aiming 60 rupees
plus what I do I take some of the
keywords which I feel like from my naked
eye at this moment are very important
for my campaign just like I take this I
take this I take this
now you can just take any of them
you can download this data into Excel
and copy paste as well so there are a
lot of ways to do this
okay and then you can certainly
just name the new ad group and they
would be added to it or otherwise it is
very easy
that we just copy them from here okay
there are ways to do it so this is the
simplest of the way suppose I just liked
all these keywords from my product point
of view and I like the pricing as well
so what I would do I would just copy
this copying this
and then putting into maybe here
so when there would be a space you know
when the campaign would ask me please
tell me for which keyword you want to
run the ad
certainly it would come here when we are
done with these two settings then I
don't have to waste time I will just go
here and copy these
keyword and paste in here under the
keywords okay I can take more but before
you know the time exhaust because I have
a uh you know in my head that I have to
complete all the campaign settings and
everything within one hour so that you
are not bored of this and I want that
energy level to be on a higher side so
you can do this research probably and
you can also you know add a lot of
keywords you know dependent on how much
you know you wanna actually leverage
from them and as well more keywords
means you end up in paying your budget
uh you know in a very quick basis so
it's important that we segregate them
from the monthly searches High monthly
searches keywords are always important
because the demand is high and then we
always check the competition should not
be higher okay so I probably would not
take these you know because these are
high ones okay I can delete and I can
always aim the low ones like medium
medium medium and medium so I can just
take this okay so copy and we'll be
replacing these
because I got the better keywords now as
compared to the other ones because they
had the high competition keywords as
well so I'm just now aiming the medium
keywords with the higher searches and I
have just decided that I would give the
bid value or a highest bid cap of a 60
rupees because I have just seen the
average that if I have to rank for this
particular one or probably this one or
probably this one you know which are on
the higher side then I should be paying
40 50 extra as you know compared to the
low priced okay so that is how the bid
value is calculated roughly okay anyhow
you would only pay to uh you know
outrank your competitor that's how the
algorithm works like you will not going
to pay high amount it is like if three
advertisers are bidding on a certain
term then if the next one to you is
paying 2 rupee or two dollars so just to
outrank him you would end up in paying
some amount over it like 2.1 or 2.2 it
is not like that you would be paying 40
rupees so that's how the algorithm
calculates okay you you put anything as
an account as a bid value but it will
only going to take I have a CPC
depending on how the competitors are
working and how their pricing is being
given okay so just on a safer side we
give our average price but moreover to
save the cost of the CPC we work on the
quality score or on the quality of our
content and on the ad which certainly is
a very important part okay so coming
back to the campaign making we come here
and we give a bit value suppose of 50
okay this is what we have seen or rather
60 from that particular you know keyword
sheet from here 30 40 percent over this
particular keyword which is the most
important one for me and then I click
next
once this is done then I just select my
Google search Network I don't have to
select the Display Network because this
will going to put my text ad on the
different websites and apps Display
Network are good when we are running the
banner ad because we are just running
the search ad so we're just going to
keep it around the Google search result
and Google sites like Google News Google
Maps Google shop Google YouTube so all
the text ad wherever the placements can
be given so it will going to take
directly we don't put on our search
Partners too because that is again going
to lose the visibility search patterns
are like ask.com AOL New York times.com
okay so again you know it is my strategy
that I don't want to increase the
visibility outside Google I'm very happy
in showing my most of the Impressions
around Google only okay or either on a
Google widgets like these wherever the
text ad has a possibility just like you
might be wondering how come I said
YouTube so if I just go here and if I
just type again this so probably you
would see text ads on the top okay
nowadays there are a lot of Tech stats
been running so this is a tech start
okay this is not a video this is not a
banner ad this is the banner ad this is
the text ad okay so this is coming from
here only
Google sites okay then comes your
location you can run the ad on different
locations by you know sitting anywhere
suppose I want to run that for the
worldwide then I'll select all countries
and territories if I want to select
particular country like India or I want
to select multiple countries like
suppose United States
foreign
Canada
or I want to select India too
so I can do this way
Okay then if I want to exclude any of
these states probably suppose I wanna
exclude Texas from here so I'll click
Texas and I'll click exclude
I wanna
exclude probably
uh Mumbai
so Mumbai as a city can be excluded
and probably I wanna extrude Ontario
from Canada
because of XYZ reasons just to explain
the settings I'm doing this so this is
also done
okay then we also can use advanced
search where a beautiful setting of
radius can be worked and the second
advantage of advances tab is that you
are able to see the map so whatever you
have selected like we have selected
Canada and us and whatever you have
deselected or excluded will come in red
blue part included red part X2 did the
same way you would see in India as well
blue part included and this small dot
Mumbai excluded okay plus we can do the
radius targeting here suppose I sell
something within the radius of one or
two kilometers or one or two miles so I
have to just select that part suppose if
I just deselect India right now
and deselect the Mumbai exclusion as
well and consider that I have a
restaurant or a cake shop in Delhi
and probably I will also add this
keyword into my keywords so that that
matches the term if anybody searches
this I have to be seeing the character
limits that's why you have to be always
checking and changing things accordingly
okay then digital marketing Google
then simply learn till
marketing
digital
marketing
on a course probably if we can get that
space
okay
then going down and we can always see
where we are lacking right now so we
have uh not very good headlines been
added including popular keywords being
there description works well so let's
see what they give us is the idea like
so they say
we are not given any online availability
brand call to actions okay I'll just
going to play with some of the terms now
so let's just see
CTA using the ctnr
you can see the strength has improved
learn
I don't know it is actually
pausing my recording again and again and
that could be a disturbance for you guys
so I'm just taking some time so that it
comes back to normal
okay so this is how you can add up to
headlines 10 headlines and that would
improve your ad strength and last not
least you can add the descriptions which
are very relevant to the ad copy okay
try to get some headlines or
descriptions here from the landing page
okay once this is done you can just
click done here
and your ad copy is prepared you can see
here very much and click next
and then you can set up your budget so
the budget which we were talking earlier
in the Excel if I have to show you so
you got 100 clicks you have paid one
rupee for every click so you have given
100 rupees per day so this is your daily
budget which you have spent okay so you
can always decide your daily budget by
setting or customizing it you can put
anything though it is showing dollars
but this is INR you can see here this is
kind of a bug which we are seeing since
almost a month now so your average daily
cost which they say like a weekly cost
rather after 41 multiplying by 33 for
every CPC price would come to 1382 but
we are giving a daily price so we can
always divide this by seven or you know
by 10 probably so I'm just giving a
rough number 100 okay or thousand could
have been you know 500 also because it's
been given okay
so every day I would spend 500 and
accordingly my clicks you know would
come and then you click next
and your ad goes to review like they
would going to be checking your landing
page they will be checking your uh you
know uh what else the ad copy everything
can be checked and would take some time
I think I just need to change that
let me just keep it
5 am
so this is simpler
and then just click next
and publish the campaign from here
publish
so once this is done
then your ad which can be checked from
here
would go into a review part and it would
say
under review once this is approved then
your ad starts showing and you start
seeing the results like impression
clicks and CTR obviously busy whatever
we have talked about okay so this is all
about the hard making now we can see
some of the important things there like
Matrix we have discussed
all these we have discussed CPC
conversions cost per conversions
CTR the only thing which you have
noticed is the quality score so quality
score is you know completely
um the part at the backend which works
like to improve our ranking so quality
score is something which has been given
out of 10 and when we see a ad which has
already been created like suppose for
this campaign if I'll take you so if I
just go to the keywords
so every keyword been given quality
score out of 10.
okay so if any of the keyword has got 10
out of 10 it means there are three
important elements like their CTR like
how many clicks have come their landing
page and their ad copy is relevant or
not okay they see three elements how
relevant the landing page is how
relevant is the ad copies and certainly
they see how relevant being the add copy
with the search then only your CTR
increases somebody searches something in
the art shows and if the clicks are high
then this ETR goes high so that's why
the CTR the landing page and the address
has to be above average that's how you
know they Define they don't give Marks
here they give total marks out of 10
here the quality score so above average
is going to be the highest average going
to be the middle one and the below
average is going to be the lowest one
okay so if you have any issues uh in any
of these elements then your overall
quality score impacts okay this is all
the fault disco so high quality score
means you end up in paying less and you
get a better value for your money okay
that's I think the last part of it so
Google ad ratings of quality of your ads
keyword and landing pages I think this
is what been given here as well then you
check I have already shown you you check
the keyword which are the timing which
which were the best timing you have from
the ad which was the best locations your
ad has actually got the result from and
then accordingly your ad can be
optimized and can be changed you change
your budget you change your bid price
you change your location you change your
timing you change your headline it all
depends after your ad actually been
shown and then you research or you do
the analysis like you know we are seeing
which keyword is working better which
keyword is having the best of the cost
which keyword is giving you the good
impression to interaction rate like a
CTR then we check the ad copy copy you
know how the ad is working suppose if I
have multiple ads to just compare if
this ad works better or this ad works
better this ad works better so I would
just going to
be comparing these three ads which one
has given me the better of the clicks as
compared to the other one which has
given me the better CTR or whose CPC was
lesser whose CPC was higher that is how
I will be checking it okay I can always
have number of ads created under the
campaign just like are we right now we
have created one campaign one ad we can
always test with the another ad copy by
clicking this so that we can see which
ads performs better okay that's why in
this existing account you can see
multiple ads so because we were testing
which one works better so this is how
you can also make one other AD copy and
you can just click done and that would
be added to the list of ads
okay you can see now one more ad
actually been added so out of these two
which one works better would be only uh
diagnosed or checked if the ad starts
running okay you can always add your
account the you know money the the
billing part into the student settings
building summary
and from here you just need to add your
mode of payment okay you have to select
your country you have to select the
currency you know you are paying it and
then of course you would have options to
pay like debate money transfer net
banking and India paytm wallet is also
available very much available
okay so this is how guys so all this
Google ad search campaign works like I
hope you have liked the session I have
tried to keep it very simple I have
tried to also somewhere show you some of
the results from the existing campaigns
and uh hopefully you were able to create
your account for free very soon and if
you would have anything to discuss if
you have anything to ask you can write
in the comment section and if you have
not subscribed our Channel Please
Subscribe we keep coming with a lot of
uh content on digital marketing social
media marketing paid ads and a lot of
other topics as well and have a great
day ahead you can also connect me on a
LinkedIn with the name of Sachin sehgal
simply learn you can find me and yeah we
can always be connected professionally
there for any help thank you so much for
your time I hope you have liked the
session God bless take care of yourself
and your families bye
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here